[Music]  the agreeableness is ultra attractive it  depends what the woman wants to do right  if I was a woman and let's say let's say  I'm let's say I'm 22 years old and I  meet a billionaire and it's my goal to  marry this man and I go to his house and  I say wow you have so many cars put your  favorite card this one really I thought  that one too it looks so good why that  one because this is this oh really okay  I'll try and remember that that's how  you get the dude right you don't get the  dude by going well that one is about  color you're a [ __ ] dude it's it's  it may be small things it may be tiny  things but men are Ultra interested in  things like agreeableness so Ultra  interested in the idea of a woman  absorbing Our World Views we're Ultra  interested we are that's what we're  looking at